[Music]
just sat down with Vice President Mike
Pence in New York to discuss all the
controversy over the so-called
whistleblower that didn't hear it
firsthand and that complaint we talked a
lot about it other issues were focused
it on this part of the interview tonight
well part two tomorrow and also about
president Trump's call with the
Ukrainian president here's what he had
to say this Ukraine thing
oh the media is just like it's like
manna from heaven oh we didn't have a
reason to impeach but I think we do now
we're now discovering the whistleblower
it was not first-hand knowledge and even
the media is is now reporting in some
places that there was no quid pro quo
yeah what can you tell us well here we
go again
they assume the worst media takes one
report runs with it Democrats on Capitol
Hill immediately start to denounce the
president before anybody has the facts
the president's been very clear on this
he he made a congratulatory call to
president zolensky after his election
which was a landslide election built
largely on the message of an
anti-corruption campaign the president
spoke to him about our concern investing
hundreds of millions of American
taxpayer dollars in seeing him move a
reform agenda President Trump made it
clear that we've got to see reforms
we've got to see honesty in government
and his congratulatory call was all
about that he mentioned Vice President
Biden and his son in the context of us
wanting to see honest government that's
exactly what the American taxpayer would
expect here you have and maybe you can
put some context you are the vice
president for former Vice President
Biden bragging on tape that you're not
getting a billion dollars
six hours and I'm leaving in six hours
you either fire the prosecutor
why would I spread enough ire prosecutor
and son of a B they fired him bragging
almost why would a vice president of the
United States of America want a
Ukrainian prosecutor fired what
conceivable reason yes it's it's it's
really remarkable that everything that
the media wants to assume about the
president's phone call in July the Vice
President Biden admitted to on camera in
January of 2018 that he said that when
he was vice president of the United
States he he had a quid pro quo he said
to Ukrainian officials that you will not
get over a billion dollars in American
aid unless you fire a prosecutor who
just happened to be investigating a
company that Vice President Biden's son
was on the very board of and they the
making a lot of money early with no
background in oil gas or energy the
American people have a right to know and
but to have a vice president a
threatening USA that's a quid pro quo
but as the president has said in his
conversation that everyone is very
interested in now his conversation was
with President zalenski that he spoke
about congratulations he spoke about our
support for Ukraine he spoke about our
concern about corruption but there was
no quid pro quo if people want to see a
quid pro quo they just need to watch the
tape of Vice President Biden explaining
that he was kind of withhold to me I
would say blackmail
wrong that Shawn I got to tell you this
is a country that was overrun by Russia
it's a country that is still at war
Russia takes the Crimea and the don baz
province they still have we believe
Russian elements there that are
fomenting violence and are trying to
literally tear Ukraine apart and so for
Vice President Biden who was part of an
administration that refused to give
military aid to Ukraine to threaten what
remained of that aid unless they
responded to his demand about firing a
prosecutor who among other things was
investigating accompany his son served
on the board of but the American people
just deserve to know the facts but what
they can be confident of is that
throughout this process that all of our
administration of context the
president's conversation all of my
discussions with President Solinsky were
all based upon proper considerations of
how we support Ukraine how we support
their effort to end an era of corruption
in their government and advance the
interest of their sovereignty look the
American people have a right to know
what happened they have a right to know
what happened in 2016 and they have a
right to know what the circumstances
were around having a sitting vice
president threatened to withhold
American aid and and again this all the
ironic thing is is that everything that
that our critics in the media are
leveling it the president from this
phone call and leveling at our
administration everything that
everything that Democrats on Capitol
Hill are running off and describing Vice
President Joe Biden bragged about which
was was a quid pro quo withholding
American aid in exchange for a specific
action would it help the president would
you recommend you release the transcript
well that'll be a decision for the
president to make remember Shaun that
would be an unprecedented it's so
important that the President of the
United States can have conversations
with leaders around the world that are
candid that are open and and for leaders
to be concerned in the future that a
conversation with the president might
make its way into the public what under
might would undermine the ability of the
President to to have those discussions
in the future so I know the president
would like to do it I know he's looking
at all the circumstances around it but
the American people can be confident in
this congratulatory call that the
president spoke about issues that are of
interest to American taxpayers notably
corruption but there was no quid pro quo